こんにちははじめ冊はですあいつもそろそろ気付くと思うんだよね俺家に来ると
何かしらのドッキリはされるってことでお前はわかってきませんね皆さんは前記
ショック時でよく見えませんかだいたいでパターンを決まっちゃってねぇよ方も決まっ
ているというかもほぼこのボタンしかないってくらいねあのボールペンですねボール弁
はこの価値って言ったらビビってきてああ
もう
てんっ
ってパターンがめちゃくちゃ多いからな実に敗れ電気ショックドッキリっていうのは
ボールペンじゃないしかないと僕は思ってたんですけどもほか見つけてしまいました
こちらこれは僕の iphone ではあります電気ショックが流れる iphone
ですこっちが普通が僕の iphone なんですけどどうかの健康でちょっと
作りこんでるんですよ at ミニかなりクオリティーは高いんですよ
ちょっとこれカメラ誰かのところ作りが
なんでこれでバレちゃこの本ぼたん荘強力な電流が流れますそのまま行っちゃっとバレ
ちゃうんで俺はどうぞあもうこのドッティのために買ってきましたからね iphone
6ラセルの iphone 県でさあ最終的に iphone 6プラッ
ドッキリにかける情熱が違うわけでプレイをつけていきましょう
ブーバーいる ok ちょっとへちょっと f んです
なんとか言いましたないってわけでこれ国交を押す電流が流れますちょっと試しに試し
にやってみましょう
あーこれ本当はのほんと強いんですねちょっと待っておりやんだよねるんっ
うわぁ
ナルシカにでぱねぇテストで受けなきゃダメだからっ
これっ
これ
今ちょっとわかるやっぱりつかなくなっちゃうと過ぎればいいじゃないっ
1いたいたこれ何度ケース受け皿なんなかったら電気通さないからなぁはケース付とが
何内蔵ケース付けたからなんだぜ
スターバックおっに金属部分の子がなんか関係してるのかなこっこ花火富士られている
と電気が流れないみたいです
買ったりひどいて出そうかなロック画面見てみたいなこういう感じでまたさんを自然
ですこれでいこう
私て持てば多分過ごせばん炊事場って本当に本当に強いから黙ってくれ出身だがしない
よね皆さんじゃわかりづらいと思うんですけどめっちゃ強いです
ああそれにだまされると思います iphone 買えたんだーって言ってちょっと
ロック画面見てやってる
私でポストさ診断
早速線としていきましょうでばいいよや早速迎えに行ってきます
はい
できるう
そうだよ
あってもあるで何か見えなくなるぞねえ
早分
てさー
今日はドッキリ常受け合わせだよ
普通はさせ彼氏ないよ
あーレイアウトです結婚と言うと思いますし
fate 見つかったんだけどぞ
盗んでやろう
なんかじゃ日本カッター
ちょっとロックが見ていっ
r 2
0いや
結構痛くなかった理系社員は派